so we started out I think last time
talking about this this grid games
language as an example of of a modeling
language that one might use in the model
driven engineering approach to building
software and so what I think I wanted to
do today is talk a little bit about how
that language was built how how I've
built that language how built the
infrastructure behind it and a couple of
other things that one can do with it no
that one has it
before we look at some of the code bits
Etc I thought I'd give a sort of really
rough overview of what in the model
driven engineering world we think of as
a language because we think when we
think of a language when we think of a
modeling language and modeling approach
we always think about three main things
um which are the abstract syntax
the concrete syntax
on the semantics
the abstract syntax in many ways is what
holds everything together okay so this
is the set of Concepts that we can
actually talk about in our language and
the relationships between those Concepts
okay and then on top of that
we will build
one or possibly multiple concrete
indexes and a concrete syntax is about
how do I interact with the language what
does it look like how do I write things
down in the language what do I do to
edit models in my language
it's how do I store them on disk Etc
that's all concrete syntax how do I
interact with those models that's in
there and the import one important thing
and we'll see that a little bit in a
moment is that there can be more than
one for the same modeling language so
far we've only talked about what the
models look like we've described data
structures okay we've described a
structured way of writing things down
but we haven't said anything about what
these things mean
at all and that's really really
important
a computer is done it just looks at this
and goes this is data it and unless we
tell it anything more about it it won't
know how to interpret that data what to
do with that data and that's where this
third thing comes in which is the
semantics which we talk about as well
where you say for this abstract syntax
here is what it means if you use these
Concepts and you instantiate them to say
something and write something out down
then here is how we're going to
interpret this and there's different
ways in which we can't give abstract
semantics to our languages what we're
going to see in in in our grid games
language or we've used there is we've
used an approach called code generation
which is very similar to compilers uh in
in sort of typical programming languages
for example so let's have a look a
little bit at our grid games language
and how we've built these various bits
for that language so here I've got again
my good games language with the with the
Minesweeper example on my computer and
you can see it's a textual language in
the first instance right I'm writing
down text in various structures we've
got these sort of keywords here that are
sort of color coded already and then
we've got varies whereas words Etc and
symbols that we're using to writing down
our specification so that's an element
of it the concrete syntax already is
that it's a textual language in the
first instance that allows us to to
interact with our model through writing
text editing text and looking at that
text okay the way we Define textual
language is typically is
through a grammar
and the grammar is essentially a set of
rules
that say
that that gives us
patterns that we can that we can sort of
instantiate in our text okay and so what
we've done here for example is we've
written down uh a grammar grammar rule
here at the very top that says for our
grid game for any grid game model
it will always start with the word game
then we will give the name of that game
that we're specifying then we're going
to have an opening curly brace
eventually we're going to have a closing
curly brace at some point and in between
that we'll have various other things
that we can specify we can specify these
these State cells actions
initializations fields and options and
each of these refers to another rule
here so for example here the states
refers to This Global cell States back
rule so if I go to that it tells me what
this definition of states in in sort of
the overall document looks like okay and
so that's something that starts with the
keyword States and so if I go back to
our Minesweeper game definition we'll
find that here so here is something that
starts with the keyword States and then
has the name of these states and have
some parameters and then has the actual
States inside and that's exactly an
instantiation of This Global sales dates
back rule here in case it starts with
state dates as a name possibly has some
parameters curly braces and then a set
of states and an indication of what the
start state was now technology that I've
used here specifically for building a
language is something called X text
there are a number of other similar
tools out there and importantly now
there are also tools that allow you to
build languages uh where the editing and
infrastructure Etc exists in on the web
and runs in your web browser and it off
for protection languages they're very
similar to this right and what they do
is you define this grammar which kind of
defines your concrete syntax but
indicates actually where the abstract
syntax concepts are as well and from
this you generate a lot of the code
infrastructure so you will see here on
the left in my code browser you'll see a
lot of code in there and most of that
code actually is generated more or less
directly from this grammar one thing
that perhaps particularly interesting to
look at is this class diagram here so
this diagram here that's the abstract
syntax of our language and I've sort of
started cleaning up the layout a little
bit so that we can look at this a little
bit but I haven't done the whole thing
but let's maybe just look at some of the
key bits here so we get a bit of a
feeling for what abstract syntax looks
like okay abstract Syntax for for any
language out there
is fundamentally a set of Concepts which
are represented as glass classes or as
boxes in this diagram they may have
attributes which is where we can put
data in there that specifies the
specific information we want to to
capture about this concept and then
there are relationships between those
Concepts and relationships are
represented in our abstract syntax
diagram here as edges between the boxes
okay and so we'll see here that we've
got this grid game concept which
represents a game as a whole I'll have
some information about the name and then
it has this these edges here
to these various things that can be
contained inside a grid game so for
example we can have
zero to Star which means an arbitrary
number of cell specifications and each
cell specification again has a name and
then contains various things inside of
it or we can have this Global cell State
spec thing that we saw earlier so we can
have again zero Stars so any number of
those and these then contain cell States
further down and so on and so forth okay
so this all gets generated from our
grammar but importantly the other way
around if I look at my Minesweeper
specification here that actually gets
passed into a set of objects that are
instances of those classes under half
those connections between them that
we've just seen in that class diagram
and that's what allows me to then do
more with my model okay I can use that
set of objects to do this validation for
example that we saw last time where we
were able to see oh okay this particular
state is never reached or I can use it
to specify the semantics of my language
for for example by writing a code
generator so for example here is a bit
of code that generates the classes that
Implement individual cells so what does
that do it has a grid game here and it
goes through all the cells and for each
cell it generates a file where it puts
in the code for that class and if we go
there we see what the what it does is
actually it generates some text which
I've written in here and you can see
that with the gray backing and in
various places it is now just hard-coded
text but it puts in text that it copies
out from the model right so it'll go
into those of into those interconnected
objects and it'll navigate through the
edges and between the various objects to
find the information that it needs right
so for example here it goes I'm going to
go into my cell going to the members I
find all of those that are variable
specifications and for each one of them
I'm going to generate what essentially
is a Java field declaration and so on
and so forth it's a really this becomes
taking the information in that set of
objects and turning it into text
and the tricky thing here of course then
is always to work out what's the right
code to generate and how do I generate
code that's ideally reasonably readable
but also isn't totally cumbersome and
sub-optimal and doesn't perform well Etc
some of you've asked about
why do I have to go to all of this
effort right why why do I have to do all
of this
um why can't I just write a library
um and the answer is you can okay so a
lot of what we've seen is if you look at
this class diagram for example right
this looks a lot like just standard
object oriented programming and you
could do that directly in kept okay in
fact there is something that people have
called uh internal domain specific
languages uh that does exactly that they
write libraries that where the functions
are written so that it reads like a
language okay so it's it's sort of
halfway there right if we look at our
grid game language here we might end up
then writing something like where we say
a new game and we provide the parameter
Minesweeper Dot and then we'd start
putting in all the additional
information so we might have a function
field easy that then again lets us add
with a DOT lets us add additional
information such as the width and so on
you can see you know we can write a
library that allows us to do this and it
reads like like like a language
um and that sometimes is the right thing
to do right especially if people are
using your language are people who are
ready programmers and who want to make
use of all the extra features that the
the host programming language gives them
then this may be exactly the right thing
to do but if the users of your language
aren't actually programmers then this is
perhaps not so helpful to them
um but also doing this means you are
still constrained to what your host
programming language can do and so
things like our check for uh for
reachability
yes you can implement this in here but
you can actually only run the check when
you run your program
whereas with the Standalone language
that we had we could run the chag
statically
and get feedback as we were editing this
specification
rather than having to run it and then
see oh I made a mistake okay and again
it's horses for courses right in
different contexts you will want
different things the these sort of more
internal languages may be easier to
build maybe quicker to build they mean
people who are already familiar with
these tools don't have to learn new
tools and then that may be the right
thing to do
in other contexts very much it isn't the
right thing to do one thing that becomes
really difficult if you have a library
is this thing with supporting multiple
concrete syntaxes that I sort of
indicated here briefly one thing we
might want to do for example is we're
talking about State machines here a lot
right so a very natural way of looking
at a state machine is actually visually
because we have a separate language it
becomes really easy to specify a second
concrete Syntax for that language and
I've done this here I've created a
diagrammatic concrete syntax here with a
tool uh called Sirius that that allows
us to to build these graphical syntaxes
really easily and really declaratively
and what I've done is that this is a
diagram of the state machine
that's defined in this model over here
already and they're they're linked
together okay so if for example I go in
here and I add this additional
transition into my tech in my textual
model then you'll see that that appears
over here in the diagrammatic model as
well and if I again remove remove this
here uh then it disappears there as well
okay and in fact I can do the other way
or do it the other way around as well
where I edit things that can added
things in the diagrammatic side of
things and they get reflected over into
the textual model okay because actually
they're both the same model
it's both the same abstract syntax
representation they're just being edited
through different concrete syntaxes
okay and that's something that's
essentially impossible to do when you
have a library but becomes possible when
you have your own language and that
means you can then provide different
stakeholders in say a larger software
development project with different
perspectives on your model that are
captured in a notation that's familiar
to them that's usable to them and that
makes it easy for them to contribute
their expertise to the overall project
people have asked about what's the
what's the cost of this and when where
so and therefore why would I do it right
first off yes it is being used in
industry and is used fairly widely
um in fact quite a lot of people use it
without being aware that they use it
right if you've ever written a
kubernetes script essentially you're
doing this if you've ever used react
essentially you're doing this
but there are places where people do it
sort of more explicitly a lot of sort of
the systems engineering world is moving
increasingly towards what they call
model-based systems engineering which is
a lot of this there's a lot of building
models building these structured
representations of large and complex
systems and they're all various moving
Parts in order to be able to stay in
control of all of that complexity so
where you have large and complex
problems
it becomes worthwhile the effort of
building this additional infrastructure
another area where it becomes worthwhile
the effort is where you're going to
build similar systems again and again
but there's some complexity to the
differences between those different
institutions okay and there I think
comes into play what we sort of call the
cost benefit curve I think of MD which
you can sort of Imagine like this if you
had a diagram here whereas or if we have
sort of time
and an effort and we want to sort of
sketch out how that develops over time
then if you have a regular project where
you don't use
mde your effort would probably be you
know something like this it would
largely stay at one level and give or
take but obviously there's variations
over time if you have an mde project and
in particular you have one where
you have this situation where where
you'll be building similar systems again
and again over time then your cost
benefit curve looks probably a bit more
like this and again you know I've drawn
it as a clean line but it it'll wobble
so you'll have this bit at the beginning
here where you invest fairly heavily
into building the languages and the code
generators and evaluators
but then over time that effort and cost
actually more ties amortizes as you're
building more of these systems as you're
benefiting more from the additional
analysis capabilities that you're
getting
um and so on and so over time your
effort will Pro will probably actually
end up being lower than if you'd not
done it but you know you've got to be
aware that there is this initial
cost of building the infrastructure
the way you do this is you click on one
of these cells and it then tells you
whether there is a mine there or not and
if there wasn't a mine then all is fine
and as in this example here you might
see a little number that tells you let's
just write a very silly little Python
program so I can write this function let
me make a little bit of a bigger font
size for you